welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Steven Wilkinson vanilla Connie
professor of India and South Asian
Studies and professor of political
science and international affairs at
Yale University much of Professor
Wilkinson's work focuses on India and
ethnic violence his book votes and
violence electoral competition and
ethnic riots in India was co-winner of
the American political science
associations 2005 Woodrow Wilson prize
for the best book published in
government politics and International
Affairs today we'll talk with him about
his current book project on colonization
democracy and conflict
welcome professor Wilkinson Thank You
Milo let's begin with an overview of
your book and the questions that are at
its foundation so the main question I
look at is why of colonies done so
differently since independence
especially why I have colonies that seem
to be superficially similar there are
French colonies for instance or British
colonies or Portuguese why given these
similarities do they seem to have done
so differently in terms of their levels
of democracy their levels of ethnic and
other kinds of conflict or their levels
of governance how did you come to write
this book what was your inspiration so I
think part of it was my fascination by
the question in India why India and
Pakistan have done so differently since
independence India has had a much
happier experience with democracy with
its management of ethnic conflict with
its level of State strengthen governance
than Pakistan even though both were part
of the same country the British colony
of India prior to 1947 so part of the
inspiration is just how do you
understand things like that these
differences given similarities within
the same Empire I think the second
aspect is related to my interest in
ethnic conflict I'd want to be
understood in working at which kind of
systems can moderate ethnic
phlex why some countries seem to have
higher levels of violence than others
and obviously in answering that question
it's important to get a sense of where
colonies start some countries become
independent with much higher levels of
ethnic conflict ethnic imbalance than
others and so you need to get a good
sense of the colonial legacy if you're
going to answer that kind of question
and then the third issue I think is that
the way in which political scientists
and economists have tended to look at
these questions have used very blunt
indicators of the colonial experience so
for instance they use were you French or
not French
or were you British or not British and
the fact is that there were enormous
difference is not just between empires
but also within empires so for instance
in the British Empire at the point of
Independence some colonies have 250 or
300 years of experience running
democratic institutions and other or at
least electoral institutions if not for
them fully democratic and other
countries have had essentially no
experience with running their democratic
institutions some countries are highly
ethnically imbalanced others aren't so
there's enormous variation across these
countries that I didn't really see out
there in the existing work that was
being done and so I wanted to develop
better indicators of those kinds of okay
so the data collection and its analysis
play a very important role in your book
tell us about it yeah so in in data most
of the interesting questions I think in
almost any field it's very difficult to
answer them with data that are just off
the shelf right there is no free lunch
and data analysis and so if you're
interested in in getting better answers
you often have to just go out and do the
hard work of gathering the data yourself
and I'm interested really in the three
kinds of aspects of the colonial
experience that I think are most
important one is looking at the legacy
in terms of party development on
electoral institutions during the
colonial period if you compare different
states how many years of electoral
institutions have they had what kind of
party systems have they had how much
experience with alternation of
government those kinds of things the
second thing is levels of he
Capital Development what it's done are
locals running the state at the time of
Independence in some states like the
Belgian Congo it's a it's mainly
Belgians who are running all the higher
parts of the state and there isn't much
training and not much capacity
underneath them whereas in other states
like India for instance you have the
very top reaches of the colonial civil
service are 50% perhaps or even more
than 50% people from the local community
at the time of colonization so there's a
very different capacity there that
doesn't mean that they were fully
democratic fully free but still you have
different levels of of inheritance and
then the third kind of thing that I'm
interested in is ethnic imbalance some
states were ethnically much more
imbalanced than others at the point of
Independence and you could be doing very
well in terms of your level of democracy
or your level of human capacity training
at the point of Independence but if all
those goodies are going to members of
one group then you're in for trouble and
that nowhere is the story between India
and Pakistan okay so how did you
actually get the data it seems like a
quite a bit of data would be required
yes so secondary sources
archival sources basically going through
with a team of a search assistance there
must have been probably 10 research
assistants of various points in the
project together with with me working
reading through lots of secondary
sources weeding through lots of archival
sources on 144 different countries you
can't look at every aspect of those
companies but you can at least get some
sense of how they vary over the most
important kinds of variables so why is
it important to look at colonial
legacies um
I think the most important reason is
that they still have a substantial
impact on the companies today in many
cases so to come back to the Pakistani
case Pakistan's army today is very much
a product of the colonial period in
terms of its regimental composition in
terms of its ethnic balance you cannot
understand the role of the army in
Pakistan and
composition of the Pakistani army unless
you understand the colonial inheritance
nor can you understand why Pakistan has
had such a bad experience with democracy
compared to India so in that way it
fundamentally shapes many countries I
think the second main reason is because
even if you're even if you don't care
about colonialism all you're interested
in is economic growth or institutions or
democracy even if you care nothing about
colonialism the fact is that the
colonial legacy influences your analyses
or ought to influence your analyses of
how all these other things work and if
you don't get a good sense if you're
doing a large cross-national analysis of
what the colonial legacy was it's very
difficult to come up with good
explanations there that are going to be
accurate on how these other things work
democracy institutions unless you get a
good sense of the colonial period so in
intercourse is an ongoing book progress
that's not it's not quite finished yet
but one of the big ones and this is in a
co-author of paper with Massimo Anuradha
who's from the Kona University in Italy
is the the longer the electoral
experience before independence even if
it's not fully a free electoral
experience and in the way that we would
think of free democratic institutions
the better you're going to do in terms
of your likelihood of being democratic
after independence so the stock of your
democracy at the point of Independence
makes a big difference to how you're
going to do subsequently one of the
second things is just the ethnic
imbalances a point of independents make
a huge difference to your likelihood of
a conflict so you could be doing really
well in terms of your electoral
inheritance but if your ethnic lis very
imbalanced in the military in the civil
service or in who gets access to
politics you're headed for trouble about
the point of Independence and then the
third thing is that the human capital
experience also makes a difference so
just to give you one instance it's
impossible I think to understand
the Belgian Congo which is not a state
with Congo and how it's done since
independence without realizing that a
year before independence in the Belgian
Congo they had 5000 senior civil
servants not one of whom was Congolese
they had an army with a thousand
officers not one of whom was Congolese
they had 14 to 20 depending on which
estimate you read university graduates
in the entire country of 14 million
people and basically just a few hundred
high school graduates as well this is a
country that in all respects is not
prepared for independence other
countries India has a hundred thousand
students in university in the 1930s you
know they have much better legacies in
terms of where they are at the point of
Independence and it's impossible to
understand how the countries do unless
you got a sense of where their starting
points are at a point with independence
and final question what was the greatest
surprise to you and doing the research
um I think there were several surprises
one was that many colonies didn't
actually make money I went into this
thinking that many of the colonies were
pure exploitative colonies and I think
they were exploited too but the fact of
the matter is that a lot of them didn't
make money the Germans for instance
heavily subsidized their colonies that
was one surprise I think another
surprise was the way in which countries
are not prisoners of the past that good
policy decisions have been able to turn
things around in many countries Tanzania
Singapore inherited very ethnically
imbalanced armies but managed to turn
the situations around and more generally
the importance of the individual I went
into this thinking that a lot of the
colonial legacies were going to explain
a very large part of how countries had
done after independence and that I think
they do but it's also important to
realize that the difference between
having a Jinnah and Pakistan and an
arrow in India after 1947 also makes a
difference on leadership problems in the
colonial period in post-colonial period
justice in our own era play a large part
in explaining the kind of outcomes you
get go to good leadership masters
good thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
research well thanks for us for more
information about Professor Wilkinson
and his work please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you